iran's ambassador to london today said
that he believes saudi arabia is trying
to draw america
into a conflict with his country is that
true that's ridiculous
saudi arabia has made it very clear that
we want to avoid war at all costs so has
the united states so has the united arab
emirates
the escalation has always been from the
iranian side and we hope that they will
change their aggressive behavior
act like a normal country what should we
be preparing ourselves we've had these
tanker attacks we have an american
military buildup and then we have this
attack on the drone today should we be
ready for war
we're trying to avoid war at all costs
we are consulting with our allies and
our friends to see
what options we have and what steps can
be taken in order to deter iran iran has
to understand that this aggressive
behavior is not sustainable
but is it getting closer conflict do you
think we hope not but
if the iranians keep acting in this
direction then they're the ones who are
escalating
sending drones to attack pipelines and
attacking
ships and threatening freedom of
navigation and one of the world's most
critical water passageways that has an
impact on the price of oil and that has
an impact on the supply of energy and
that has
impact on the global economy is not
acceptable providing ballistic missiles
to terrorist groups like the houthis and
hezbollah is not acceptable
planting terror cells in other countries
is not acceptable assassinating
diplomats and blowing up embassies is
not acceptable
iran must understand this that's why
it's under sanctions it's not under
sanctions because they didn't do
anything but your argument to america as
i understand it was to that iran needs
to be put back in a box
maximalist policy needs to be applied
and yet since that's been applied iran
you're saying is is getting more and
more out of hand that that is not
working is it
well we have to see how how it we how it
moves forward
the jcpoa was signed people thought iran
would become a normal country it didn't
they took the resources and used it for
evil
they i don't recall them building one
hospital or one road in iran but i but
we saw them doubling down in syria and
in yemen
so obviously the funds went for evil
purposes not good purposes
now that the united states has taken a
firm position against iran which we
support
we believe that the pressures are going
to increase tremendously on iran
in order to force them to change their
policies
people ask me a lot at the moment should
we be ready for war is war coming how
worried are you
we're you're always worried about things
getting out of
out of uh out of control but we have
made it very clear that we want to avoid
war at all costs
and we have made it very clear as has
the united states and really
the the burden is on iran to stop its
aggressive behavior
moving on to another subject the british
court of appeals today has ruled that
future arms sales licenses will have to
be suspended
that's a major setback for you and the
uk government isn't it
it's a domestic british matter that has
to do with licensing and i believe the
court wants the british government to
make changes to its licensing process
and i believe the british government
will do so
and then i believe we will get to a
point where the the the licensing will
resume
but it is the product of years of
lobbying by mps human rights
organizations
ngos activists you're losing the moral
argument over yemen aren't you
we have taken a hit on yemen definitely
i believe it's because
people have not looked at it objectively
we did not start this war the houthis
did we entered nine months after it
started at the request of the legitimate
government based on yuan resolution 2216
we have made it very clear that the
solution in yemen is a political one
and yet we're blamed for it we don't use
child soldiers the houthis do we don't
plant mines
the houthis do we don't lee siege on
towns and villages and starve people the
houthis do we don't steal humanitarian
assistance and sell it for profit
that causes the world food program to
suspend distribution of food in yemen
the houthis do
we don't lob ballistic missiles at towns
and villages the houthis do
and yet the world has given the houthis
a pass and this is not
i believe neither fair nor acceptable
nor accurate
we have supported every agreement that
was made since this crisis began
as as the yemeni government and the
houthis have reneged on every single one
of them
so who's to blame here are we to allow
yemen a critically important country to
be taken over by iran
and hezbollah that's not an option
that's that would be catastrophic not
just for saudi arabia but for the world
on khashoggi in this u.n special
reporter report yesterday i know
i know you're saying that she's biased
and you're not happy with the report
but it does say that every expert
consulted finds it inconceivable
that an operation of this scale could be
implemented without the crown prince
being aware
at a minimum that some sort of mission
of a criminal nature directed at mr
khashoggi
was being launched the problem is it's
not just the u.n is it it's the cia
it's republicans in congress it's
foreign intelligence agencies
all saying that your crown prince had an
involvement i don't believe
i don't believe that they're saying this
i think that's what people attributed to
them
the there is no evidence the the the
idea that the crown prince was
responsible for this or directed this is
ridiculous
we have denied it we said this is not
the case the uh
abu ghraib happened is uh was the
president of united states aware of it
no he wasn't iran contra happened was
ronald reagan aware of it no
it these are rogue operations we have
made it very clear
that uh though we will investigate and
we will
hold people accountable and we will
punish those responsible and we now have
a number of individuals on trial in
saudi arabia five of whom are facing the
death penalty
we have reviewed the procedures of our
intelligence service to ensure that
mechanisms are in place to prevent
something like this from happening again
but what this report is saying is that
your crown prince should be amongst the
men in the dock
effectively and lindsey graham one of
your greatest friends in in washington
says
we will make a definitive statement the
mbs knew about it
and is responsible for it and the cia
has said they have high confidence the
order to kill came from the very top how
can you keep denying it
i don't believe that the case the cia
had confidence high confidence that
saddam hussein had chemical weapons
didn't turn out to be correct we are
investigating the investigation is
ongoing
the trials are ongoing people will be
held responsible and people will be
punished
let me ask you i'll be put to you what
some people say to me which is that
saudi arabia says it's changing i think
you said to us a year or so ago
san diego is becoming a normal country
it won't be long before it's like lots
of other countries since then you have
murdered your government
agents at least have murdered a
journalist in one of your consulates
you are accused of beheading or planning
to behead and crucify
activists some of them who are children
when they're arrested you're still
holding women activists
who've lobbied and campaigned for women
to be able to
drive what's going on have we been
conned by this idea that saudi arabia
is modernising and changing i think this
is misinformation
the individual the women who were held
were held because of
uh recruiting people in sensitive
government positions in order to take
documents and give them to
hostile powers outside of saudi arabia
this is the reason it's not because of
activism
why would you want to jail a woman who
advocates for women driving
when the king lifted the ban on women
driving well that doesn't make sense
because because this judgment is based
on wrong information the idea that saudi
arabia would execute
an individual for a crime he committed
when he was 13 is ludicrous our laws
prohibit this
where did that come from the court
issued a judgment that says
12 years including time served which i
believe is five years
with four years suspended how people
jump to the conclusion and says hajib is
going to execute somebody for a crime
they committed when they're 13
is beyond me people seem to fire first
and ask questions next when it comes to
saudi arabia so this is all just
bad pr is it partly i think we have to
explain ourselves better
partly i believe that people need to be
less biased when it comes to saudi
arabia
for some reason just like with the
houthis we are portrayed as monsters and
they're portrayed as angels
but when you look at the facts they're
the cause of the problem in yemen but we
get the blame
but saudi agents murdered a journalist
and the world should just move on we
acknowledged it it was a ruge operation
it was not authorized an investigation
was launched
individuals were detained the trials are
ongoing and those who are responsible
will be punished severely
this is what countries do thank you very
much thank you